[Musique]
non
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro à 17,8 culture
une émission pour vous présenter les
initiatives culture et à la ddt dans les
yvelines
au programme aujourd'hui le 19 mai c'est
la date annoncée pour la réouverture des
lieux culturels musées cinémas théâtres
salles de spectacle devrait pouvoir
ouvrir leurs portes au public mais dans
quelles conditions
nous parlerons des dernières annonces ou
une exposition appelée place au coeur du
domaine de saint germain en laye la
préhistoire en bande dessinée présente
les planches dessinateur eric lebrun une
exposition réalisée à part les équipes
du musée d'archéologie nationale
et puis à saint quentin en yvelines le
musée de la ville des voix le patrimoine
de l'agglomération vidéo
vous y découvrirez le quartier des prés
à montigny le bretonneux ou encore le
quartier 17 mar à elancourt et je vous
lisez en titre les établissements
culturels devrait pouvoir ouvrir le 19
mai marque peiffer vous êtes avec nous
ce soir bonsoir bonsoir merci de me
recevoir
merci à vous vous êtes le directeur du
théâtre de poissy pour commencer en tant
que représentant d'un établissement
culturel quelle a été votre première
réaction face à cette annonce de
réouverture à la mi mai vous pensez bien
que ça faisait quelques mois qu'on
attendait qu'on nous qu'on nous le dise
donc on est ravi de pouvoir ouvrir même
si on sait que les conditions vont être
difficiles puisque pour l'instant ce qui
nous a été donné comme indication c'est
35% des jauges et des espaces de deux
sièges entre chaque spectateur
donc ça va être difficile mais de toute
façon on a décidé de de réouvrir quoi
qu'il en soit justement c'est ce que
j'allais vous demandez donc le protocole
sanitaire sera probablement le même mais
il y aura des jauges
donc vous l'avez dit à 35% par exemple
pour commencer voilà c'est ça c'est ce
qui nous a été dit pour l'instant on va
on va attendre bien évidemment alors
nous pour une salle comme comme le
théâtre où il ya plus de 1000 places
ça veut dire qu'on peut recevoir plus de
350 personnes et donc effectivement
c'est une jolie salle il ya des d'autres
salles qui auront des jauges beaucoup
plus petit bien évidemment vu leurs
capacités donc on est ravis on fait tout
ce qu'il faut on espère qu'on aura pas
refuser du monde
il y a déjà des gens qui avaient de
toute façon annulée pour pour les
derniers spectacles de la saison parce
que ils avaient un peu peur de ce qui se
passait de venir dans une salle mais on
a environ au moins 300 personnes je
pense qu'ils viendront à ce spectacle et
qu'est ce que vous pensez d'impasse
sanitaires comme ça a été peut-être
évoqué pour accéder à ces établissements
culturels à la culture écoutez je vois
pas comment ils peuvent le mettre pour
l'instant en route vu le nombre de gens
qui ont été vaccinés mais ça n'est pas
un problème de le mettre en route un
jour une fois que tout le monde sera
vacciné il faut juste que ce pas ce ne
soit pas un passeport réducteur et que
l'on puisse aussi accueillir des gens
qui font un test uniquement un test pour
pouvoir rentrer dans nos salles vous
savez je je pense qu'on ne le fait pas
pour aller dans les grands magasins
donc il n'ya pas de raison qu'on le
fasse dans une salle de spectacle où
nous sommes rodés pour accueillir du
public qui lie à des espaces qu' il y a
de la hauteur la plupart du temps dans
nos théâtres
donc c'est vraiment un des lieux où il y
aura le moins de continue de
contamination possible pour le théâtre
de poissy comment est ce que vous savez
comment on va s'organiser la réouverture
parce que on sait que les cinémas par
exemple pourront rouvrir en une semaine
mais c'est pas forcément le cas pour les
théâtres en sachant que ben en plus on
est en fin de saison
est ce que par exemple pourquoi si vous
allez plutôt attendre la nouvelle saison
où est ce que on s'apprête à rouvrir
justement a commencé dès mai et mi mai
vous comprenez bien on a on a continué à
travailler et à ouvrir le théâtre
qu'on a reçu des troupes de théâtre de
musique
on a reçu des circassiens ils sont venus
répéter
ils sont venus en résidence ils ont
préparé leur travail donc si vous voulez
le théâtre de poissy n'était pas du tout
totalement fermé mais on ne peut pas
arrêter cette saison sans avoir ouvert
au moins sur la fin de cette saison donc
en 2021 au public
donc on fait tout ce qu'il faut pour que
le vin c'est à dire le lendemain des
autorisations on puisse accueillir du
public et on va pouvoir le faire avec
leur caisse de l'alliance qui vient qui
nous proposera un concert de musique
classique autour de cra au cde et de
mozart qu'on pourra donc retrouver en
inde et dès la mi mai en tout cas
puisque vous allez ouvrir le 20 mai
mérite absolument le 20 mai et en plus
de ça on va enregistrer un album ce jour
là et on va certainement tourner le
concert pour que l'on puisse avoir des
images qui seront peut-être sur une
télévision a ensuite fermé merci
beaucoup max et faire d'avoir été avec
nous
merci et puisque je voulais juste vous
dire mais ce sera l'occasion d'en
reparler une autre fois c'est que nous
préparons la rentrée dès septembre et
que nous aurons la chance de pouvoir
accueillir l'estival avec deux autres
villes des yvelines mais ça on en
reparlera une autre fois parfait le
message est passé en tout cas et puis
oui on en parlera avec plaisir merci
beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir été avec
nous je le rappelle est vous êtes le
directeur du théâtre de poissy
[Musique]
une exposition a pris place au domaine
de saint germain en laye la préhistoire
en bande dessinée présente les planches
dessinateur eric lebrun c'est
l'exposition était initialement prévu
pour les salles du musée due à la crise
sanitaire elle s'est montée en extérieur
regarder la préhistoire en bande
dessinée 45 panneaux ont été installés
au coeur du domaine de saint germain en
laye objectif de l'exposition montré un
panorama de l'art préhistorique
depuis les origines aux alentours de -40
milan jusqu'à la fin du paléolithique
aux alentours de dix mille ans de moins
dix mille ans au moment où le climat se
réchauffe les panneaux mettent en avant
les planches du dessinateur eric lebrun
l'exposition est basé sur les trois
volumes 2 bd l'art préhistorique en
bande dessinée
vous avez ces planches de dessins issus
des trois des trois bd qu'il a réalisé
lors de la prise de la préhistoire et au
verso se trouve en fait une autre bd
dont il est scénariste
les planches sont en lien avec des
objets appartenant aux collections
préhistoriques du musée d'archéologie
nationale des collections pour l'heure
visible en ligne grâce à des qr codes
comme par exemple les venus nous voyons
de sa tête féminine dont qui
représentent des femmes enceintes qui
ont été trouvés en dordogne une à tursac
et une à sireuil que l'on peut bien sûr
retrouver dans les vitrines du musée
dans la galerie du paléolithique
et puis il ya aussi une petite dame qui
est très connu qu'on appelle la dame à
la capuche
l'exposition s'adresse à tout public une
phase est prévue pour les enfants des
planches sans paroles c'est l'histoire
d'un petit enfant de cro magnon qui
découvre là qu'ils découvrent l'art en
fête en mettant ses mains dans la boue
en laissant des traces derrière lui et
de l'autre côté donc c'est un petit peu
plus pour les parents entre guillemets
donc ça raconte vraiment les différentes
périodes de la préhistoire
une exposition proposée jusqu'à 1000
septembre elle est accessible à tous
gratuitement depuis septembre 2020 le
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines propose et d'éviter des vidéos
du patrimoine de l'agglomération
ces vidéos sont disponibles sur le site
de 50 ans
une rue blick rubrique culture en ligne
mais aussi sur leur chaîne youtube celle
de sky et le site internet du musée de
la ville s'il y avait 400 go bon soir
bonsoir
donc c'est bien a expliqué nous quels
sont le genre de vidéos proposées bien
trois différentes thématiques existe ce
sont d'ailleurs les trois champs d'étude
du musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines
d'abord patrimoine et territoires une
série qui présente le patrimoine saint
quentinois l'art à l'air libre autour
des oeuvres d'art dans l'espace public
et la minute design qui présente les
collections de design et mode de vie du
musée de la ville une fois par mois les
trois vidéos sont publiés est-ce que
vous avez un exemple à nous donner
justement
oui pour la série patrimoine et
territoires justement de nombreuses
vidéos ont été tournées dans saint
quentin en yvelines comme par exemple le
quartier des prés à montigny le
bretonneux le quartier champfleury à
voisins le bretonneux ou encore le
quartier 17 mar à elancourt
regardez donc la vidéo suivie de la
réaction de la responsable de l'action
culturelle de la ville du musée de la
vie bienvenue au quartier 17 mar à
elancourt il s'agit du premier quartier
à avoir été construite lors de l'
aventure villenouvelle 50 ans ni gay les
été inauguré en 1975 en octobre 1975
c'est par la fête est inauguré le centre
déchets soit elle nous permet de montrer
aussi des images d'archivés la
documentation qu'on a au sein des
collections de musées qu'on n'a pas
toujours l'occasion de montrer en
général donc les saint quentinois
connaissent le musée de la ville soit
pour l'aspect collection ou soit pour la
proche patrimoine mais finalement très
rarement sur le volet arts publics et
oui et donc le musée de la ville a voulu
mettre en avant ce dernier volet la
passerelle de la gare de saint quentin
en yvelines le pont de grateloup ou
encore la perspective de marta pan sont
des oeuvres majeures de l'agglomération
ça permet de mettre vraiment en avant
des oeuvres qu'on ne voit pas forcément
et d'intelligent aller les voir au
détour d'une promenade et à découvrir
ses richesses là et donc quelles seront
ses il ya les prochaines vidéos à
découvrir à la fin de la semaine trois
nouvelles vidéos seront proposés pour
les collections du musée ce sera sur les
essoreuse à salade
du côté de l'art à l'air libre vous donc
vous découvrirez une vidéo sur la grande
girouette une oeuvre dans le quartier
des saules à guyancourt et enfin pour la
partie patrimoine et territoires se sera
sur le quartier de la haye bergerie à
villepreux
merci célia garde son goût d'avoir été
avec nous son analyse courte mais 78
elle a été récompensée par la plus haute
distinction de l'artisanat la vie
sinoise laurence baby maîtres artisans
sa spécialité la tapisserie elle
travaille notamment depuis quatre ans
sur les rideaux du château de breteuil
une découverte de ce patrimoine
artisanal dans ce reportage de nicolas
landry
des rideaux 9 pour le château de
breteuil trois paires au total pour le
vaisselier la salle à manger
la couleur bleue a été choisi une
nécessité pour être raccord avec les
autres éléments de la pièce c'est un
très joli soie sauvage que laurence baby
pu doubler d'une en occultant ce qu'il
faut aussi protéger les tissus et les
tapisseries
depuis quatre ans maintenant laurence
baby travail pour le château de breteuil
à son actif trois paires de rideau
refait pour le salon de musique une
paire de rideaux pour le vestibule et
des rideaux occultants pour l'orangerie
un espace dédié aux réceptions on a eu
quand même 80 mètres de tissu
des échafaudages pour poser les rideaux
seront était à 6 mètres sous plafond et
peu près 20 kg par ha pardon uniquement
installé à voisins le bretonneux l'
artisan tapissier est spécialisé dans la
création la rénovation de fauteuils ou
de rideau elle a reçu récemment le titre
de maître artisan la plus haute
distinction dans l'artisanat
là ça y est c'est le petit espace qui
existe c'est vraiment très réduits sur
sept ce petit fauteuil sur l'endroit où
est on peut mettre tout les accroches
tel l'ancien coussin de cette bergère
qu'on est en train de restaurer et je
vais faire ce pas ce poids là on a coupé
dans le billet que le tissu est
et donc on met une ganse de 3 mm je
passais sous la machine artisan
tapissier un véritable savoir faire
technique entre artisanat et métiers
d'art une activité essentielle dans la
conservation du patrimoine historique
un reportage réalisé avec grigoriy
canale et c'est la fin de ce cette fuite
culture merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi prochain pour une
nouvelle émission et d'ici là portez
vous bien
[Musique]